this is the report that ended Dominic
Robb's career took five months to write
almost 50 pages Adam Tully Casey upheld
two complaints about the behavior of
Dominic Robb one when he was foreign
secretary the other when he was Justice
secretary let's look at both so here's
from when he was foreign secretary and
Adam Tolley found that the former deputy
prime minister acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
he found that his conduct also involved
an abuse or a misuse of power in a way
that undermines or humiliates his
conduct was bound to be experienced as
undermining or humiliated by the
affected individual and it was so
experienced now let's look at his time
as Justice secretary
and here Adam Tolley describes how
Dominic Robb would get frustrated when
some of his steers his recommendations
about proposed reforms hadn't been
implemented in the papers that were
being presented to him and he describes
that there was a bit of dispute over
exactly what dominic Robb said whether
he said the word was utterly useless or
woeful but then totally concludes on
balance I think that these were the
words used they comprise criticism that
was not in the nature of constructive
feedback they were reasonably understood
as insulting personal criticism
then there's some of the context around
the Pavia at that time this is also from
Dominic Robb's time in the ministry of
justice and he talked to Dominic Raab
who made clear that he takes a strong
view the former Minister that officials
should be prepared to answer questions
about the things that they're presenting
to him and if they don't he's quite
prepared to offer criticism in the words
of tolly unconstructive criticism what
dominic Robb would do is he'd talk about
the lack of basic information or the
basics that they were able to provide
now Tully's view is that this is
unacceptable he says it's likely to be
experienced as an unfairly personal
criticism by the individual to whom the
comment is directed and was so
experienced by some individuals viewers
will have to decide whether or not it's
right for a minister to get cross
because civil servants apparently not
doing their job
uh but then there is this Dominic Robb
makes another allegation that the
political prior the policy priorities
included uh including the Bill of Rights
and reforms to the parole system were
not liked by the Civil Service uh
Dominic Robb perceived what he described
as a cultural resistance uh to these
policy uh items amongst others uh in his
remit so he's alleging that civil
servants in some cases were biased and
not doing what he wants but the most
toxic allegation also from his time as
Justice secretary and that's because
there was a big group complaint that was
made to Adam Tolley a group of Junior
civil servants all working together now
Adam totally admits he doesn't know how
many people were involved but look at
this
only some of those individuals in this
group had any direct experience of the
Deputy Prime Minister some had never
even met him at all but were seeking to
support their colleagues I think some
Tories when looking at that sentence
might be wondering whether some people
in Whitehall had an agenda